you talked about this it was a fake
documentary
yeah and that were it was all about how
the abbreviations for states write about
and you wrote this routine and it was
just you did it on our show and as I
said it got just incredible reaction
from people everywhere and also from
some of the best comedians saying wow
that's set that you did it is the
biggest thing I've ever done in my
career yeah I'll have seen that than
anything yeah and it was really
beautifully crafted how long did that
take you to write was it was it so
perfectly worked out and if you haven't
seen it you can go online and look up
Gary on this show doing it was amazing
but right now yeah let's play it we need
to fill some time yeah so I first wrote
it in my notebook in 1994 about six
months into comedy and the entire world
had to change in order for me to
convince people that there was a
documentary about something as unusual
as abbreviating the states down to two
letters so how Vetta
had to have come out this documentary
about the font yes yes it's so funny cuz
when you talked about it I think a lot
of people thought it was a real
documentary you were making it up but we
live in a world where every day they
come out with a new documentary you see
him on the UH Netflix all the telly and
they're about the most ridiculous thing
yes about a font about a man who is
excellent at slicing sushi yeah hero
dreams of sushi yeah yes yes they're all
riveting yeah the way yeah and so I
finally had this idea I'll tell people
it's a fake duck or that it's a real
documentary and I still have people
emailing me and asking me where can I
find that it should make it yeah